[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره اخباريه جديده
من العربيه على مدى تسعين دقيقه نتابع مع
حضراتكم اهم الاخبار عربيا واقليميا
ودوليا وسيكون لدينا نقاش ايضا لابرز
قضايا الساعه البدايه بالعناوين
لدخولي من قاضها اجواء امريكا بالخطا
وتقول ان الرياح هي السبب
يقول ان المنطقه لا يشكل تهديدا وهو قادر
على المناوره وقد غير مساره
الرئيس بايدن طلب عدم اسقاط المنفاد
وتاجيل رحله وزير خارجيه المرتقبه الى
وعايزين نسكي يضغط من اجل وعب سياسي بدمج
بلاده في البيت الاوروبي وبروكسيل تتعهد
بدعمه حتى النصر
وفي نشرتنا ايضا ماسك يقول ان تويتر
ستشارك عائدات الاعلانات مع بعض صانع
المحتوى لكن بشرط امتلاكهم للعلامه
الزرقاء
وبعد ساعاتنا الاخباريه سنفتح ملفي النقاش
هدوء بين الفلسطينيين واسرائيل لكن النار
تبقى تحت الرماد حكومه نتنياهو تواصل
مصادره الاموال وتضييق على الاسرى
[موسيقى]
الدولار صحيح في مصر حديث في العراق مفقود
في لبنان اسعاره احرقت الجيوب والموائد
وهوت بالطبقات الوسطى
اهلا بكم ماجل وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطوني بلينكل زيارته الى الصين على خلفيه
ازمه المنطاد الذي يحلق في الاجواء
الامريكيه في المقابل تراجعت بكين على
لهجتها الحاده في ازمه المنطاد الذي يحلق
فوق الاراضي الامريكيه الان وقالت انه
مخصص للابحاث المدنيه والطقس وعرضت عن
اسفي الانحرافه عن مساره وفي وقت سابق
كانت بكين انتقدت وبحده واشنطن لاتهامها
بالتجسس وقالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
والمغالاه لن تفيد في الامر بطريقه سليمه
واضافت ان الصين دوله مسؤوله وتلتزم دائما
بدقه القانون الدولي
اكد المتحدث الرسمي باسم البنتاجون ايضا
ان نظام الدفاع الجوي الذي يغطي منطقه
امريكا الشماليه يستمر في رصد ومتابعه
منطاد المراقبه الصيني الذي يحلق على
ارتفاع اكثر من 60 الف قدم
يوم امس المراقبه ليس الذي الكثير لاقوله
نظام الدفاع الجوي يستمر في مراقبته بشكل
لصق لن نخوض في تفاصيل مكان تواجد المنطاد
لكن يمكنني ان اخبركم انه يستمر في التحرك
شرقا وهو حاليا فوق المنطقه الوسطى في
الولايات المتحده لا نعتقد ان المنطاد
يشكل خطرا عسكريا على المدنيين وسنستمر في
تقييم الوضع
اجواء مشحونه بين واشنطن وبكين في الارض
والسماء منطاد صيني يحوم في سماء امريكا
لاهداف تجسسيه وتعقب متواصل لمسار حركه
المنطاد من قبل البنتاجون تصريحات مسؤول
الدفاع الامريكيه اوضحت مسارى ووجهه
المنطاد الصينيه فقبل عده ايام اخترق
المنطاد الصيني المجال الجوي الامريكي
ونحو قواعد جويه ومخازن صواريخ استراتيجيه
في ولايه مونتانا شمال غربيه امريكا يحلق
المنطاد عاليا على ارتفاع اعلى بكثير من
الحركه الجويه التجاريه وعاقب مشاورات
عسكريه امريكيه اقتربت طائرات المقاتله من
المنطاد فوق مونتانا دون ان تتخذ قرارا
باسقاته واشنطن ابلغت بكين بخطوره الواقعه
موضحه انها ستفعل كل ما هو ضروري لحمايه
شعبها على ارا تحذير واجهته الصين بدعوه
لحل المساله بهدوء وحذر
اما مجلس النواب الامريكي فطلب الاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه بعدم الصمت
ما تقوم به الصين عمل مزعزع للاستقرار
ويتجاهل سياده الولايات المتحده بدون خجل
ادعو الرئيس بايدن الى عدم التزام الصمت
وابلاغ اعضاء الكونجرس بالمستجدات
من جهته طلب الرئيس بايدن من وزير دفاعه
بحث الخيارات المتاحه مع قيادات الجيش في
البنتاغون
ووفقا لبيان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه فان
المنطاد لا يشكل تهديدا عسكريا او جسديا
لمن هم على الارض وعلى الرغم من القيمه
المحدوده للمنطاد استخباراتيا وفق مسؤولين
الا انه قد يزيد من حده التوترات الصينيه
الامريكيه العسكريه والسياسيه في شرق اسيا
علي السمان العربيه
ومن دوائر صنع القرار الامريكيه تنضم
الينا من البيت الابيض ناديه البلبيسي
مرحبا بك ناديه وينضم الينا ايضا من امام
البنتاجون الطود مرحبا بكم ناديه كانت
هناك روايه يتم طرحها في الاعلام الامريكي
بان بيض كان يريد ان يتم التعامل مع
المنطاد بشكل ما والبنتاجون كان له وجهه
نظر اخرى دعينا في الصوره حول مطرحه
البنتاجون وماذا كان رد فعل البيت الابيض
اهلا بك رشا اعتقد رسميا البيت الابيض لم
يعلن عما كان يدور في خالد الرئيس لكن كما
تعرفين منذ بدايه هذه الازمه في الساعات
الصباح الاولى كان هناك مكالمه هاتفيه مع
وزاره الخارجيه التي قالت بان دخول هذا
المنطاد الى الاراضي الامريكيه ولا
الاجواء الامريكيه هو انتهاك صارخ
للقوانين الدوليه ولسياده الولايات
المتحده لكن بعد طبعا علم الرئيس بايدن
بمجرد ما وصل الخبر الى القاده العسكريون
والبيت الابيض هو الذي يقرر بالنهايه وليس
البنتاجون اعتقد بان الرئيس بايدن لا يريد
ان يكون هناك بالفعل توتر كبير مع الصين
وخصوصا وانه بلنكن كان المفروض ان يغادر
هذه الليله لذا بعد وصول المعلومات
الاستخباريه لديه بان المنطاد لا يشكل
تهديدا عسكريا او استخباراتيا الولايات
المتحده قرر يقوم باسقاطه وربما كان راي
اخر للبنتاكول لكن حتى الان هذه النقطه
غير
يمكن ان يكون حسين لديه معلومات حول هذا
الامر ناديه كيف بدا السيناريو في
البنتاجون للتعامل مع هذا المنطاد والى
اين وصل
تحيه لك رشا المتحدث باسم وخلال الاجازه
الصحفي الذي قدمه قبل قليل رفض اعطاء
الكثير من المعلومات ووصفها بان معلومات
سريه ولكنه اكتفى بالقول بان المنطاد تحرك
او يتحرك الان شرقا من مونتانا قال ان
المنطاد لديه القدره على المناوره وقد غير
مساره هذه نقطه مهمه ثالثا قال بان
البينتكون يراجع جميع الخيارات
والاحتمالات للتعامل مع هذا المنطاد عندما
سئل هل سيتم اسقاط هذا المنطاد او متى
سيتم اتخذ القرار وما هي العوامل التي
ياخذها بالحسبان قال انها كثيره هم ياخذون
بالحسبان الموضوع ده حجم المنطاد واذا كان
اسقاطه سيؤثر على المواطنين الذين يعيشون
في المنطقه اسفل المكان المتواجد به ولكن
هو اكد على ان هذا المنطاد لا يشكل تهديدا
عسكريا ولا تهديدا جسديا طالما انه موجود
في الاجواء ولكن لم يحدد متى
اسقاطه او كيف سيتم التعامل معه واكتفى
بالقول بان هناك خيارات عده طبعا اوضحه
المتحدث باسم البنتاجون بات رايدر في
الحقيقه ضحض قليلا ما جاء على موقع
24 الذي وصف بان البالون موجود او المنطاد
موجود فوق الاباما
اكد عليها انه لن يعطي معلومات دقيقه حوله
ولذلك المعلومه حول وجود المنطاد حاليا
غير معروفه الذين يعرفونها فقط هم من هم
الموجودون داخل وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
نعم اعود الى زميلاتي ناديه ناديه دوائر
صنع القرار السياسي في امريكا كيف تتعامل
مع هذا التطور هل يتم تقييم الامر وفقا
لما يتم رصده في وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
او لدى هذه الدوائر السياسيه ان مرحله
جديده من المواجهه قد بدات مع الصين
موضوع التجسس بشكل عام هو موضوع ازلي فما
بالك بين بكين وبين واشنطن هو معروف منذ
فتره وقبل قليل كنت استمع الى بعض
التحليلات العسكريه الذين قالوا بانه
الاستخبارات الامريكيه تتلقى ربما كل خمس
ساعات اشاره بان الصين حاولت ان تتدخل
بشكل ماس وكانت في المواقع الالكترونيه او
القرصنه او لا غيره لكن وجود هذا البالون
او المنطاد في داخل الاراضي الامريكيه
بالفعل احدث صدمه يعني كان هناك مطالبات
في الكونجرس باسقاطه بشكل سريع وحتى
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب طالب ايضا
باسقاطه تدخل بالموضوع وهذا احدث بعض
الضغط ربما على الرئيس بايدن ومن هنا جاءت
الغاء رحله بلنكن الى بكين يعني البعض يرى
بانه ربما هذا المنطاد كما شو هالاخير
سريعا جدا ناديه هذه الزياره التي كانت
مقرره لبلنك لم يتم الاعلان عنها سواء قبل
ساعات من هذا الحدث هل هناك تفسير لهذا
الامر
لا كانت
الليله في الواقع والبيت الابيض يقول
وزاره الخارجيه بانه تم تاجيل الرحله لم
يتم الغائها وان القنوات الدبلوماسيه
مفتوحه مع بكينو نوعا ما واشنطن قبل
التبرير اذا اردت بين قوسين الصيني وهناك
قضايا كبيره هي لا تريد ان تلقي موضوع
موضوع البالون او موضوع المنطاد بظلال
قاتمه على مواضيع مهمه مثل كوريا الشماليه
التي يوادر الرئيس بايدن تشيشي بالحديث
فيها نعم ما دلاله موجوده في الفضاء
الامريكي وبالتالي نحن سنتابع تطورات هذه
الازمه زملائي ناديه البلبيسي من البيت
الابيض شكرا لك ناديه وايضا الزميل حسين
الطوب من البنتاغون شكرا لك
وفي مقابله مع العربيه قال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الولايات المتحده
تعتبر المنطقه الصيني ذا طبيعه تجسسيه
من جانبنا نحن نعتبر هذه المنتج منتج تجسس
نعم بدون
استكشافات
وتحقيقات وسنعرف اكثر في الايام المقبله
ولكن الان نحن نعرف هذا المنتج المنتج
البالون لا يمثل اي خطر للمدنيين ولا يمثل
اي خطر للطائرات المدنيه في امريكا اذا
نحن سنستمر في المراقبه
وسنعرف اكثر بعد الايام
وينضم الينا من واشنطن جاش وفاه زميل في
مركز الامن الامريكي الجديد وبرنامج امن
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ مرحبا بك سيد فات
هناك تساؤلات تتعلق بالعوده الى فكره
استخدام المنطاد كاداه للتجسس وليست
الاقمار الصناعيه ما دلاله هذا
اعتقد
ان الامر
يرجحه انه تجسس من خلال هذا المنطاد
والتصاريح الاتيه من الصين تقول ان ان
المدنيين او الطائرات او غيرهم لن يتاثروا
لكن التصاريح التي تاتي من الصين
تقول بانه قد كان حادثا بحيث
قد ظل المنطاد طريقه بسببه اوضاع جويه
وهذه التصاريح
التي نسمعه من الصين تقول بانها تعبر عن
الاسف
وفي هذه الايام وفي ظل الاجواء الحاليه
بين الصين والولايات المتحده فان الصين لا
تستخدم كلمه تاسف او عن سلوكياتها وهنا
مربط الفرس ولكن السؤال الذي يتم طرحه كما
ذكرت لك في البدايه لماذا الى المنطاد
للتجسس اذا كان هو اداء الان يتم
استخدامها للتجسس يعني البعض يعتقد ان
الزمن وتكنولوجيا تجاوز ذلك الى فكره
الاقمار الصناعيه
[موسيقى]
وخاصه ان خدماتي الاستخبارات الصينيه قد
يكون لديها صوره مختلفه عن استخدام
المنطاد من الاقمار الصناعيه لكن كما
ذكرتم في تقريركم من غير المرجح بان هذا
بانهم سوف يحصلون على اي شيء جديد من خلال
استخدام المونتاج على مدى الفتره الماضيه
كانت هناك ما يسمى بالاستفزازات الامريكيه
للصين وكانت الصين صامده هذا التحرك
الجديد من قبل الصين هل هو يعذب بمثابه
مفاجاه بالنسبه لاداره بيض في تعامل الصين
معها خاصه مع ملفك التجسس
عندما يتعلق الامر
في الولايات المتحده لديها سياسه عبرت
عنها بوضوح لمده عقود من الزمن
والسبب في ذلك يعزى الى ان الوزير لينك
كان سوف يتوجه للصين ليس فقط من اجل قضيه
تايوان فحسب بل على مر السنوات الخمسه
الماضيه فان العلاقات الصينيه قد تدهورت
بشده وكانت تلك فرصه مناسبه لاعاده طرح
وتقديم بعض المسؤولين على مستوى الرفيع من
حيث
بغيت تخفيف هذا التوتر ولكن هذا الحادث
الاخير الذي نحن بصدده الان الى اي مدى
ممكن ان ياخذنا الى نقطه حقيقيه للمواجهه
ما بين الصين وامريكا
من المؤكد
انه انها اوقات صعبه ويؤسف لها
ولعل الامر قد يكون حادثا كما ذكرت الصين
ولعلها كانت ترغب فعلا باطلاقه يصعب عليه
ان يتخيل ان المسؤولين الصينيين
كانوا ليتوقعون ان الولايات المتحده سوف
تستمر في عقد اجتماعها رغم ذلك الحادث لكن
هذا الحدث على وجه التحديد لن يكون لديه
اثر دائم على طبيعه العلاقات فان العلاقات
الامريكيه الصينيه واسعه النطاق
وتدور في مجالات
مختلفه منها الدبلوماسيه والاقتصاد
والمنخ وهناك قضايا مختلفه تجمع
الولايات المتحده والصين ويجب عليهما
الانخراطي بها بصوره عامه العلاقه قد لا
تقف عند حادثه ما بعينها
رغم انه ولسوء الطالع لابد من تاجيل
الزياره وهذا يبعث برساله مهمه
بشان تاجيل هذه الزياره من خلال اشعار
قصير رغم رغبه الطرفين بحدوث تلك الزياره
واشنطن
الامريكي الجديد وبرنامج امن المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ شكرا لك
ازمه المنطقه هذه تذكرنا باجواء قديمه
تعود الى عقود مضت ورغم عيوب المناطيد الا
انها ما زالت تحتفظ ببعض المميزات منها
المساحه التي يمكن ان تغطيها والتكلفه
الزهيده نتابع
في يوم مشمس نظر سكان ولايه مونتانا
الامريكيه الى السماء ليخطف نظرهم هذا
المنطاد
لم يعلموا حينها ان ذاك الهيكل هو بالون
تجسس
سريعا كشفت السلطات الامريكيه سر المنطاد
لتعلن انه تابع للصين
بالونات التجسس ما هي لمعدات قديمه اعيد
استخدامها في عالم التجسس الحديث مفهوم
بالونات التجسس ظهرت لاول مره عام 1860
اثناء الحرب الاليه الامريكيه تقول صحيفه
البريطانيه
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه تم تحديث
مفهوم بالونات التجسس لتحل الكاميرات
المخفيه المعلقه بدلا من الرجال الذين
يحملون المناظر لمراقبه العدو
لم تكت تنتهي الحرب العالميه الثانيه حتى
اطلقت اليابان اول قصف جوي عابر للقارات
مستهدفه الاراضي الامريكيه من خلال مناطيض
مسلحه اطلق عليها فوجو مصنوعه من الورق
والحرير الصناعي وخلال خمسه اشهر فقط
اطلقت اليابان نحو 9000 بالون صوب
الولايات المتحده وفقا للمتحف الوطني
للقوات الجويه الامريكيه استفادت امريكا
من التجربه اليابانيه لتدشن بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه مهمه واسعه النطاق تسمى
مشروع جينيتريكس للتجسس فوق اراضي الاتحاد
السوفيتي خلال فتره الخمسينات عبر مناطيد
التصوير
اذا ما قررنا المنطاد بالقمر الصناعي فانه
يتميز بتغطيه مساحات اوسعه ويتميز بقضاء
وقت اطول فوق المنطقه المستهدفه المنطاد
ايضا يتميز بانه اسهل في الاسترداد وارخص
من حيث تكلفه الانتاج والتشغيل لكن لا
يقدم المنطاد نفس المستوى مدقه والكفاءه
في المراقبه المستمره كالاقمار الصناعيه
واليوم تعمل مثل هذه المناطير على ارتفاع
يتراوح بين ثمانين الفا الى 120 الف قدم
وهو اعلى بكثير من مدى الطائرات المدنيه
ونبقى معكم ولدينا ايضا
حصريا فريق العربيه يدخل كهوف حزب كملاء
الايراني المعارض
عقب القمه الاوكرانيه الاوروبيه في كييف
تعهد الرئيس الاوكراني
تضيع بلاده يوما واحدا للمضي نحو مفاوضات
للانضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي هذا العام
مؤكدا ان الخطوه ستلهم الاوكرانيين
وتمنحهم حافزا للقتال ضد قوات الروسيه
اذا تم تسريع تسليم الاسلحه بعيده المدى
فلن ننسحب من باخموت فحسب بل سنبدا في
تفكيك دومباس المحتل منذ عام 2014
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
سيدعمك في سعيها للانضمام لصفوفه
ما هي خطوتنا القادمه الان خلال فتره
الربيع سنقدم تقريرا بالاضافه لوجود
تقارير تقدم من قبل اعضاء الاتحاد
الاوروبي عن كل الدول التي تريد الانضمام
للاتحاد ولكن يجب ان نقدم معلومات وحقائق
عن اعمال التطوير على ارض الواقع وفعاليه
الخطوات ونتائجها كما نؤكد على دعم
الاتحاد الكامل والدائم لجميع الدول ونوضح
بان الاتحاد لديه الخبره الكافيه والكبيره
في كل الخطوات للانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
شارلي ميشيل رئيس المجلس الاوروبي كان غرض
قبل القمه مشددا على عدم التهاون فيما
يتعلق بالازمه في اوكرانيا وعاد بعد القمه
ليؤكد لاوكرانيا ان اوكرانيا هي الاتحاد
الاوروبي والاتحاد الاوروبي هو اوكرانيا
اوضحت هذه القمه امرين الاول رساله لك
وللشعب الاوكراني نقول لك من خلالها ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي سيدعمك بكل الطرق مهما
سيستغرق الامر لاننا لن نهدد ولن نخش
الكرملين اوكرانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي اسره
واحده اما رساله الثانيه فهي ان مستقبل
اوكرانيا مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
ونتابع من موسكو مع مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد ومن كيف ايضا مع مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا بكم الى هذه
النشره ابدا من كييف حذيفه كانت هناك ساحه
للدعم الكبير من قبل اوروبا اليوم لزينسكي
ضعنا في الصوره حول كيف كان المشهد
طيب مساء الخير رشا لك ولزميل عبد الجواد
انعقدت القمه الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه
الرابعه والعشرين في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كييف هذه القمه سبقتها مفاوضات على مدى
يومين بين المفوضيه الاوروبيه والمسؤولين
الاوكرانيين في الحكومه الاوكرانيه شارك
الرئيس فلاديمير في المفاوضات وكانت
النتائج طبعا في هذا المؤتمر الذي انعقد
اليوم للرئيس فلاديمير زيلينسكي
المفوضيه الاوروبيه وكذلك الشعب الرئيس
المجلس الاوروبي كان هنالك تصريحات ورسائل
واضحه من خلال هذا المؤتمر الصحفي الرئيس
فلاديمير اولا اكد على ان الهدف هدف
الانضمام الى اتحاد الاوروبي هو هدف لا
رجعت فيه وقال ان الشركاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي اكدوا ذلك من خلال المفاوضات ومن
خلال هذه القمه كذلك
اكد على ذلك وقال ان مصير الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومصير اوكرانيا هو مصير مشترك
ومستقبل اوكرانيا هو من ضمن مستقبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي كذلك ارسولا قالت ان
الحكومه الاوكرانيه قطعت اشواطا جيده في
التوصيات التي قامت بها المفوضيه
الاوروبيه للحكومه الاوكرانيه لتسريع
عمليه الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي هنا
نتحدث عن قضايا الفساد ومكافحه الفساد
نتحدث عن استقلاليه القضاء طبعا الاقليات
والقوميات وحريه الصحافه وما الى ذلك من
التوصيات التي قام بها الاتحاد الاوروبي
طبعا ايضا اكدت على الدعم
الاقتصادي والمالي وقالت اننا قطعنا وعودا
هنالك 50 مليون يورو سوف يتم تقديمها
للحكومه الاوكرانيه وقد تم بالفعل تسليم
منذ ايام اول دفعه من هذه من يعني من هذا
الدعم وثمانيه عشر مليون يورو تم بالفعل
تسليمها الى الجانب الاوكراني كذلك مساله
الدعم العسكري الرئيس عندما سئل عن ضاقم
التحديدا قال اننا لن ننسحب طبعا منها
ولكن طبعا ربط ذلك بالدعم العسكري الذي
يجب ان يقدم من الشركاء
بابا هذا الدعم الكبير يمكن ان نلاحظ كيف
كان التفاعل في موسكو مع هذا الاستعراض
الاوروبي من دعم اقتصادي وعسكري وسياسي
كبير
كيف كانت الاصداء في الدوائر السياسيه
الروسيه عبد الجواد
مساء الخير رشا لك وللزميل حذيفه يعني
موسكو ما زالت تتحدث عن عمليتها العسكريه
وعن تصعيد الموقف العسكري في جنوب
الاوكراني طبعا الكثير من المواقف
والتصريحات السياسيه بما يخص ما يحدث
اليوم هناك طبعا ابرزها لو سمحتي لي في
البدايه لي بان نتطرق بان الكرملين طبعا
نفا كافه الانباء التي تتحدث عن زياره
رئيس الاستخبارات الامريكيه الى موسكو
واقتراح منح 20% من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لروسيا هذا نفاه الكرملين بشكل كبير لكن
خرج وتحدث عن عدم الثقه الكبيره بين موسكو
والغرب اليوم وان الغرب لم يتخلى حتى هذه
اللحظه عن سياساته الاستعماريه لكن طبعا
القضيه الاهم كانت
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي الذي تطرق اليوم
للحديث عن الخسائر الاوكرانيه في المجالات
والقط الاقتصاديه تحدث عن الخسائر الكبيره
في قطاعات الزراعه والصناعه والتعدين
واستخراج الفحم وغيرها لذلك طبعا نلاحظ
بان القراءه السياسيه والعسكريه بما يخص
وما يحدث اليوم
بما يخص شان الازمه الاوكرانيه ما زالت
موسكو تتحدث عن سير عملتها العسكريه تتحدث
عن ضخ ودعم كبير بما يخص المعدات العسكريه
للجيش الروسي بالاضافه الى طبعا التحركات
الكبيره على الارض
عبد الجواد وايضا حذيفه لنستعرض بعض
تطورات الخاصه بالدعم العسكري وسط هذا
الحديث عن الدعم افاد مسؤولون امريكيون
اوروبيون عن صعوبه اسابيع المقبله بالنسبه
لكييف الاسباب عديده اوكرانيا ستواجه الان
300 الف جنديه على طول الخطوط الاماميه
كما ان روسيا في طريقها لهجوم موسع في
الشرق تستبق به وصول المساعدات العسكريه
الغربيه لك
اكدوا كذلك ان كييف ستكون مضطره قريبا
للتخلي عن مخمود لانها معركه مكلفه بشكل
يفوق اهميتها الاستراتيجيه
لا ننسى ان رئيس الاوكراني يرفض حتى الان
التخلي عن مخمود لماذا ربما تكون الاجابه
في الاسلحه المنتظره من الغرب والحديث هنا
لا يتوقف على دبابات ابرامز 2 بل اسلحه
قتاليه قد تسمح لك باستعاده زمام المبادره
تحدث قبل قليل ان دفعه المساعدات الجديده
لاوكرانيا ستشمل صواريخ ذات مدى ابعد اما
واشنطن بوست الامريكيه فكشفت النكيات
تنتظر دفعه جديده من سلاحها المفضل في
بدايه الحرب وهي صواريخ جفلن المضاده
للدبابات بالاضافه الى منظومه صواريخ
هايمرز ومن اجل مرونه اكبر في المناوره
ستزود واشنطن بمئه وتسع مركبات مصفحه من
طراز برادلي وتسعين ناقله جند مصفحه من
طراز اسرائيل بولندا السخيه للغايه مع
اوكرانيا اعلنت تزويدها ب 30
ببطاريتين من انظمه
للدفاع الجوي الى كيا بينما ستتكلف لندن ب
30 قطعه مدفعيه ذاتيه الدفع من طراز اي اس
اعود مره اخرى الى مراسلي العربيه عبد
الجواد الرز من موسكو ومن كييف حذيفه عادل
حذيفه هذا الاعلان عن هذا الدعم العسكري
الكبير
او لاوكرانيا هل من جداول زمنيه تم
الافصاح عنها لهذا الدعم وفقا لتصريحات
الحكومه الاوكرانيه
نعم في الحقيقه هنالك ثلاثه الى اربعه
اسابيع سوف تصل معظم الاسلحه التي سوف
تسمح لكيف بالسيطره على جبهات القتال
تعلمين ان هنالك هجوم شرسه الان في اتجاه
ضخمه من قبل القوات الروسيه والقوات
الاوكرانيه في الوقت الراهن طبعا هنالك
نقطه مهمه لابد من توضيحها الجيش الاتحاد
الروسي قام بنقل مخازن الذخيره والوقود
والقواعد العسكريه الى مدى حوالي 120 كم
من الجبهه تعلمين ان سلاح هايمرس هو الذي
شكل فارقا في الهجوم المضاد للجيش
الاوكراني هذا السلاح الان هو يصل الى مدى
80 كيلو مترا لذلك لا تستطيع القوات
الاوكرانيه ان تضرب يعني المخازن الوقود
والذخيره والسلاح والقواعد العسكريه
لتصعيب عمليه
الدعم اللوجستي للقوات في الجبهه لذلك
اليوم كان في البلاد في اوكرانيا وزير
الدفاع البولندي التقى الذي كان في المؤ
الصحفي للقيمه ولكنه غادر بشكل سريع لقاء
لوزير الدفاع البولندي وهنا الحديث دار عن
اف 16 وان هنالك مفاوضات نشطه تجري مع
الشركاء في النيتو وان هنالك مفاوضات تجري
هذا القرار الخاص 16 لن يتم وفقا لبولندا
الا بعد الاتفاق مع حلف النيتو او دول
النيتو وعوده الى عبد الجواد هذه الصوره
من الاستعراض الجديد للدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا من الحديث عن عقوبات من المستوى
الكبير ستدخل مرحله العاشره بالنسبه
لروسيا كيف كان صدى هذه الاخبار في موسكو
رشا يعني رئيس البلاد فلاديمير بوتين
ووزير خارجيته
ووزير دفاعه
ومجلس الامن الروسي معظمهم يتحدثون خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه عن ان موسكو لن
تقف مكتوفه الايدي حيال تزويد كييف بهذه
المعدات العسكريه الثقيله طبعا بوتين تحدث
يوم امس بلغه صريحه ووجهه رساله للغرب
مضمونها بان موسكو لديها يعني ما يكفي
للقيام بالرد على مثل هذه الاستفزازات
العسكريه كما وصفها لذلك طبعا يعني موسكو
حذرت بشكل كبير من تصعيد هذه الاعمال
العسكريه بشكل خطير والوصول الى مرحله
استخدام السلاح الثقيل في الجنوب
الاوكراني وفي المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه عبد الجواد على
كل هذه الحديث يدور عن مقات او مدرعات او
صواريخ عبد الجواد الرشد المراسل العربيه
من موسكو شكرا لك على هذه المعلومات وايضا
الشكر لزميل يا حذيفه عادل من كييف
ونبقى معكم مشاهدينا ولدينا
ليفربول الانجليزيه من المنافسه على كل
الالقاب الى محاوله انقاذ الموسم فقط
اهلا بكم نذكر حضراتكم باهم التطورات قلعه
الخارجيه الصينيه ان المنطاد التي تم
اكتشافه في الاجواء الامريكيه يستخدم
لابحاث الارصاد الجويه وعرضت بكين عن اسفي
لدخول المنطاد المجال الجوي الامريكي بسبب
قوه الرياح
اعلنت الولايات المتحده عن حزمه مساعدات
من الاسلحه والذخيره الى اوكرانيا بقمه
تصل مليارين و200 مليون دولار تشمل قدره
دفاعيه جويه حساسه وصواريخ عاديه وطويله
المدى لمساعده اوكرانيا
نقلت وسائل الاعلام من المانيا عن مصادر
ان برلين تتحدث مع السويد لشراء منصات
اطلاق لتعزيز انظمه الدفاع الجوي الموصله
لاوكرانيا المنصات السويديه ستصهم في
حمايه منطقه اكبر من الهجمات الروسيه
كشف جهاز الامن الاوكراني عن مخططان طن
لسرقتي اموال مخصصه لامدادات الغذاء لقوات
الدفاع وقال ان الاضرار التي لحقت وزاره
الدفاع نتيجه هذه الاليه الاجراميه فقط
ثلاثه ملايين ومائتي
قال رئيس الوزراء بن يمينه ياهو ان الرئيس
الفرنسي
لبحث عقوبات على الحركه الثوريه الايرانيه
واضاف ايضا ان هناك تقارب كبير بين
البلدين في تقييم تهديد الايراني
حضر نشاطات في ايران من تعرض المتظاهرين
في مدينه زهدان عاصمه محافظه سيستان للقمع
العنيف خاصه مع وصول عدد من كبار القاده
العسكريين الايرانيين للمدينه للاشراف على
عمليه القمع
وزير خارجيه تركيه الدول الغربيه التي
اغلقت قنصليتها في اسطنبول بعدم تبادل
المعلومات حول تهديد الامني الذي ادى
للاغلاق كما تم تشوش اوغلو الغرب بشن حمله
نفسيه ضد تركيا
اجتمع رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي احمد مع
قاده اقليم تجريل لاول مره منذ اتفاق
نوفمبر
خطوات تنفيذ الاتفاق والقضايا التي تحتاج
مزيدا من العمل
والعوده لمتابعه ابرز الاخبار والتطورات
بعد عام من الماساه الطفل المغربيه ريان
الذي توفي جراء سقوطه في بئر في منطقه
شفشوان شمال البلاد رزقت الاسره بطفل ذكر
ولد في مستشفى مدينه تطوان وفي تصريح
لصحافه المغربيه قال رب الاسره ان ولاده
طفل في نفس التاريخ هو معجزه بالنسبه
للعائله
وزميلي عادل الزبيري من مدينه تطوان ومعه
والد
ريان ومعه ايضا والد الطفل وهو والد الطفل
الجديد ربما نتعرف على اسمه
مرحبا رشا مرحبا رشا تحيه من منزل عائله
السيد خالد اورام والد الطفل الفقيد ريان
او الرام التقينا انا وانت على الهواء
مباشره قبل سنه في لقاء مع السيد خالد
وبعد سنه تقريبا ترزق العائله بمولود جديد
ذكر لم نعرف بعد اسمه ومعنا هنا في منزله
السيد خالد سي خالد السلام عليكم مرحبا
بنا عندكم اولا مبروك
اخترت شي اسم للمولود الجديد ولا مازال
اخترنا واحد السميه ساجد اذا رشا اول
معلومه هذا المولود الذكر اسمه ساجد ساجد
اسم جميل
الان بعد سنه من فاجعه ريان الله سبحانه
وتعالى يعودكم خيرا احساسكم
ذكرى فيها حزن وايضا فرح مع المرور الجديد
ان تمك عائله كيف تعيشون هذه اللحظات
كيفاش كتعيشو هاد المناسبه
فرحان الحمد لله ربي رزقنا بهذه الوليد
الحمد لله فرحانين
الحمد لله
اسمح لي غادي نفكرك في ريان مازال كتذكره
هذاك الطفل
استحضرت الذكرى ولا فقط حنا الصحفيين
كيفاش شفتو في العائله هذا الهبه الرباني
او هاد الهديه الربانيه الله سبحانه
وتعالى تفكركم بمولود ذكر واش كتشوفو انه
تعويض على راي الله يرحمه
شويه الحمد لله ربي عوضنا ولكن يعني ريان
في القلب يعني
الحمد لله انسان
قدامه او يرتاح النفسيه
ولكن بالنسبه للريان
يعني واحد
انت السي خالد بغينا شويه
الله يرحمه اللي كنا عشنا معك القصه كامله
شنو مازالك كتذكروا وعاد نهضروا على ساجد
ان شاء الله
دائما حاليا كنت تفكر ريان الله يرحمه
الله يرضى عليه
رب العالمين الان كي عامله احوالكم انتقلت
من القريه قريه اغران كنظن هذا هو الاسم
الصحيح في ضواحي مدينه شفشاون انتم الان
في تطوان كي عامله الاحوال عامله الاوضاع
كي عامله الحياه والله سبحانه وتعالى
اعطاكم هديه واخترت لها اسم جميل ساجد
يعني البلاد يعني كتبقى في البلد دائما
يعني انتقل لتطوان باقي
يعني شويه كتجي شويه القنت ولكن الحمد لله
في المواصلات ديالو
يكون المستقبل احسن
من الجبل تماره
انت الان مرتاح في المدينه في تطوان امورك
مزيانه كتحس ان الحياه رجعت لطبيعتها بعد
سنه من وفاه ريان والله تعالى رزقك بساجد
الله يا ودي يعني شويه دابا كنحز براسي
مزيان ملي جات الدريعه وشويه
كنحز بالراحه والفرحه
والحمد لله على
عندك نعم نعم رشا انا اسمعك نعم نعم
ظروف المعيشيه وعن عبور نعم حينما علم
بخبر حمل زوجته هل كان يفكر في انه يريد
مولود ذكر ليعوضه عن ريان
حسنا سانقل السؤال الى والد ريان خالد سي
خالد يسالك الزملاء في العربيه عندما علمت
بخبر ان الزوج حامل ان شاء الله
هل تمنيت ان يكون المولود ذكر هل كانت هذه
الامنيه ام قلتي كما كنقولو في المغرب
اللي جاب الله مرحبا
من بعد ما اعطاك الله هاد الوليد شعورك
احساسك واش هو تعويض واش هي هديه وشحال
اللي كنقولو حنا في المغرب ربي ابتلاك
بالفقدان ريان وايضا اعطاك هذه الهديه
الثمينه ديال ساجد
من عند الله سبحانه وتعالى ربي يعوض عطاني
هذا الوليد يعني هديه من عند الله
نعم
المغاربه
يعني
رشا والد خالد سعيد جدا بالمولود الجديد
والعائله اتفقت على تسميته بساجد ربما هي
اشاره سجود والامتثال الله عز وجل وفق
الثقافه المغربيه الاسلاميه وهو ايضا صابر
لانه لا يزال يتذكر ريان ذلك الطفل الجميل
غير المشاغب الودود اللعوب في تلك القريه
الجبليه في ضواحي مدينه شفشاون العائله
بصراحه سعيده جدا شكرا لك عادل على مقلب
تحاول نعم العربيه الان على الهواء مباشره
في هذا الحوار الخاص مع والده الطفل ريان
والذي رزق في ذكرى وفاه ريان بطفل جديد
اطلق عليه اسم ساجد شكرا لك عادل الزبيري
مراسل العربيه من مدينه تطوان
وعربيا اشتعلت الامور بشده بين رئيس
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل نور الدين
الطبوبي ورئيس التونسي قيس سعيد مع اتهام
الطبوبي للرئيس بتهديد التونسيين عبر ثقنه
عسكريه في اشاره الى خطابه الاخير من سكنه
العوينه رئيس الجمهوريه التونسيه
في الليل وهو ما تعود عليه
انه يخاطب شعبه
بالتهديد والوعيد
من سكنت الجيش او من مقر وزاره الداخليه
او من سكنت الحرس الوطني
رئيس الجمهوريه انه اليوم
يسحب الانظار على النتائج الهزيله والحضور
معناها الضئيل والضعيف
لمعناه الانتخابات في الدور الاول والثاني
باش تسحب الانظار على الفشل الذريع في كل
الخيارات الاقتصاديه
وتداعيات المجتمع التونسي هو انه
ده بس يقول انه الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل اليوم دورك
اهلا وسهلا في البدايه يعني نتحدث به
السيد نريد الطبوبي ليس مفاجئا وليس هذه
قيمه لاننا نعلم جيدا ان هذا التصريح
الغير متوازن ما يمكن ان نصفه ياتي في وقت
يعاني يعاني فيه مؤسسات الاتحاد من
ارتدادات جراء الازمه التي تعيشها منذ
مؤتمر سوسه يوم سبعه يوليو 2021 والذي
اعتبر تماما بانه مؤتمر غير شرعي لانه نقض
ديمقراطيه وتاريخ العمل الديمقراطي داخل
الاتحاد الذي يمنع الامين العام من الترشح
لمرتين لاكثر من عشره سنوات داخل المكتب
التنفيذي وبالتالي السيد نور الدين
الطبوبي اليوم في اطار البحث عن الازمه
لانه يريد ازمه من اجل اذا كان هذا هو
موقفوبي والاتحاده هل هذا يعني ان ليس
هناك ازمه سياسيه تواجه الرئيس قيس سعيد
بعد نتائج الانتخابات بهذه المشاركه التي
وصفت عالميا ودوليا بالهزيله
اولا نسبه المشاركه هي ليست نسبه لها
علاقه بالرئيس قيس سعيد لاننا شاهدنا ان
الرئيس عندما دعى الشعب التونسي الى
الاستفتاح على الدستور شارك ما يقارب 3
مليون تونسي في الاستفتاء عليه هذه
المشاركه وهذا العزوف هو جراء موقف شعبي
تونسي فاقد الثقه بالبرلمانات التجربه
الديمقراطيه البرلمانيه ومجلس النواب
المشكله في تونس ان الشعب التونسي بعدما
راه في عشريه الخراب من مهازل تحت قبه
مجلس النواب فيما جرى من هدق وتهدمير
للسياسه للسياده الوطنيه في اغراق تونس
مجلس النواب كان الاداء التي اغرقت تونس
في ديون تزيد عن تسعين
الانتخابات من دعى اليها بشكل واضح هو قيس
سعيد وبالتالي اعتبر الكثيرون
على برنامج قيس سعيد
الاول الدعوه للانتخابات ليست للتصويت على
برنامج قيس سعيد ولكن للتصويت من اجل
انتخاب اعضاء جدد في مجلس النواب هذه
القضيه ليس هنالك برنامج قدمه قيس سعيد
لان قيس سعيد ليس له حزب ليقدم له برنامج
ولكن القضيه ان هنالك نقطه النقطه الاولى
ان الشعب التونسي لاول مره في تاريخه
يشارك في انتخابات تحترم المعايير
الديمقراطيه الغربيه التي تقوم على مبدا
الانتخاب على الافراد وليس الانتخاب على
القائمات التي هي عباره عن تحيل ديمقراطي
وكذب باستعمال الديمقراطيه الغير شايفه
ايضا على انها النسبه الاقل في تاريخ تونس
منذ الثوره
نعم علينا ان نذكر ان النسبه كانت في11
51% انخفضت في 2014 الى 41% انخفضت في
2019 الى 31% في انتخابات مجلس النواب
علينا ان نذكر ان الرئيس قيس سعيد في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في 2019 حصد اصواتا
اعلى من كل الاصوات التي حصلت عليها
الاحزاب في انتخابات 2019 التي دخلت لمجلس
النواب وهل تعتقد انه ما زال يحظى بهذه
الشعبيه وبهذا التوافق الوطني
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد لاننا نعلم جيدا انه
قبل خمسه اشهر حصد ثلاثه مليون صوت ايدوه
في الانتخاب في الاستفتاء على الدستور
واليوم امامنا قضيه بسيطه جدا وهذا ما
قالته القوى الاطراف الدوليه لمن دعوها
الى التدخل من اجل اسقاط قيس سعيد قالوا
لهم ان هنالك انتخابات رئاسيه في 2024
اجتمعوا واسقطوه وبالتالي اذا كانوا هم
يعتقدون ان الشعب معهم فما زال للانتخابات
الرئاسيات 19 شهر في تونس الاقل من سنتين
وبالتالي ليس هنالك ما يدعوهم الى هذا
بامكانهم ان يسقطوه ديمقراطيا وان ياتوا
بمرشح لهم ثقه الشعب
من تونس تحياتي
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق مايك
مومبايو خلال لقاء تلفزيونيه مع قناه فوكس
نيوز قال انه عندما كان مديرا لوكاله
المخابرات المركزيه التقى برئيس كوريا
الشماليه كيم جونغ اون الذي ذكر له انه
حان او حاول قتله مسبقا لياتي رابط
بالتاكيد بانه لا يزال يحاول قتله ابان
فتره عمله سابقا
تمويل هذا حدث وان كان هناك امريكي اعيد
جثمانه الى الوطن بعد ان كان معتقلا في
كوريا الشماليه وتوفي اثر سوء المعامله في
المعتقل وبالتالي دخلت الاجتماع وانا مدرك
ان من سيقابلني على الطرف الاخر من
الطاوله سيكون شخصا قتل امريكيا وانه شخص
شرير تقدمت لاصافحه واذا به يقول لي عبر
المترجم الفوري انه متفاج من حضوري
للالتقاء به رغم انني حاولت ان اقتله من
قبل تفاجات للوهله الاولى اذ لم يكن ابدا
في حسباننا ان يقول مثل هذا الشيء عندها
قررت ان اميل عليه بعض الشيء وقلت له
فخامه الرئيس ربما مازلت احاول ذلك ربما
انصدم للوهله الاولى عندما وصله حديث عبر
المترجم لكنه سرعان ما بدا الضحك
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه اكد قائد قوات
البشمركه في حزب املاء الايرانيه المعارض
ندير مهراوه ان الحزب يحتفظ بقواعد
كردستان العراق لحمايه نفسه وانه يدربون
عناصر البشمركه تحسبا لاي مواجهه مع
النظام الايراني اما
ايران ليس لديها نظام ديمقراطي بدلا من
ذلك لديها نظام قمعي هذا النظام حرم الناس
من حرياتهم ولا احد يستطيع التحدث بحريه
نحتفظ بقواعدنا في كردستان العراق لحمايه
انفسنا وحمايه اولئك الذين تعرضوا
للاضطهاد من قبل النظام نقوم بتدريبهم
ونساعدهم ليصبحوا بشمركه لذلك اذا كنا في
يوم من الايام نحارب النظام عسكريا يمكنهم
الدفاع عن انفسهم لكن في الوقت الحالي لا
نشارك في اي نشاط عسكري ومع ذلك فاننا لا
نزال مستعدين لاي اثناء تدريب كوادرنا
والبشمركه في اقليم كردستان علينا حمايه
انفسنا هنا ايضا
نظام الايراني بمواصله انتهاك سياده
العراق واقليم كردستان بشكل يومي من خلال
الحدود ونشر عملاء استخبارات تابعين للحرس
الثوري
ديمقراطينيه تواصل الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
انتهاك سياده العراق واقليم كردستان بشكل
يومي النظام ينتهك الحدود ويطلق طائرات
مسيره وينشر عملاء استخباراتيه تابعين
للحرس الثوري
نتعرض باستمرار لتهديد قوات النظام
الايراني لذلك يجب ان نكون مستعدين في
جميع الاوقات لحمايه انفسنا وشعبنا
لم يهدا غضب الاوساط العراقيه بعد الاعلان
عن مقتل طيبه العلي خنقن على يد والدها
وفي احدث حيثيات تلك القضيه نشر رئيس خليه
الاعلام الامني في العراق سعد معين تغريده
قال فيها بانه ومن خلال طبيعه مهام عمل
دائره العلاقات والاعلان في وزاره
الداخليه فقد تمت متابعه قضيه الفتاه
والتوصل لضمانات مع عائلتها بعدم التعرض
لها الا ان السلطات الامنيه تفاجات بخبر
مقتلها على يد والدها
احرز النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
هدفه الاول في الدوري السعودي لكره القدم
وجاء الهدف خلال مباراه فريقه النصر ضد
مضيفه الفتح ضمن منافسات الاسبوع الخامس
عشر من البطوله المحليه وانقذ رونالدو
فريقه من الخساره امام الفتح حين نجح في
تسديد ركله جزاء في الوقت المحتسب بدل
الضائع محرزا هدف التعادل الثاني ومانحا
النصر نقطه قادته الى صداره لائحه الترتيب
وكان النجم البرتغالي انضم الى صفوف النصر
السعوديه خلال يناير الماضي قادما من
مانشستر يونايتد الانجليزي
هنا اول اللحظات كريستيانو يعلن الا
فتتاح به
والى الدوري الانجليزي الذي يشتهر
بمنافساته التي لا تقطع للقواعد ففي
الميدان لافارق بين نادي كبير وصغير وكل
النتائج وارده لكن حتى في احوال الانديه
لا قواعد ليفربول العريق في الموسم الماضي
هو كالغريق في هذا الموسم ما دفع كلوب
للتعليق سؤال جدا لم اصبح مدربا سيئا بين
عشيه وضحاها لست جيدا كما يعتقد البعض
لكنني لست سيئا كما يقول اخرون من موسم
الى الذي يليه تبدل حال ليفربول الانجليزي
مع مدربه
بشكل ماساوي الموسم الماضي كان النادي
العريق يخوض السباق للفوز برباعيه تاريخيه
دوري ابطال اوروبا والدوري الانجليزي
والكاسيين المحليين هذا الموسم فقد
الكاسين
للمركز التاسع في الدوري وحتى في دوري
الابطال تنتظره مهمه شديده الصعوبه امام
البطل ريال مدريد
فتحت هذه النتائج بابا الانتقادات واسعا
بحق يورجن كلوب المدرب الذي اعاد هيبه
الفريق عبر اكثر من سبعه مواسم يرصد محبون
ليفربول اسبابا عديده للتراجع منها
الاستغناء عن لاعبين ذوي ثقل كالسنغالي
ساديو ماني واستقدام اخرين لم يقدموا
المامول كالبرتغالي داروين نونيز هذا طبعا
فضلا عن موجه الاصابات التي ضربت كل خطوط
الفريق تقريبا اخرون حملوا الاداره
المسؤوليه بسبب تقاعسها عن تلبيه احتياجات
الفريق وربما لهذا السبب اسيل الكثير من
الحبر مؤخرا عن نيه مالك النادي بيعه في
كل الاحوال يبقى لقاء الريال منعطفا اخيرا
فاما ان يستعيد الخلطه التي حققت
الانجازات واما ان يبدا الحديث على الارجح
عن مدير فني جديد
كانت هذه ابرز الاخبار بعد الموجز نفتح
النقاش حول ملفين اليوم